[Musik]
viel Spaß wie hin und weg wünscht ihnen
Dr Oetker
[Musik]
ich kann hier als Schweiz
Kindheit von erster Augenblick martin
war sehr sehr was das der hübsch für
mich
sie haben gesagt
[Musik]
zeig mir
Rever you meeting
[Musik]
der Thomas Kleiber wandert
aus
dem Schweizer Fernsehen
freue mich auch ich freue mich
freue mich da David gesehen ich freue
mich dass
schwierig also man muss ja wirklich
unter Druck dass man über Monate
speziell Sieden wieder nach unten wieder
zurück in Barnim Modus oder und jetzt
haben wir sogar single-modus kam und
emotional sind die Wacht also muss ich
sagen
[Musik]
Abschied von der älteren und denn
zum Beispiel wohne im Haus von der
Schweiz
[Musik]
hallo
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
warum
als Beraterin für grossrunde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie schwierig oder wie einfach das wird
einfach aber glaube
so weit weg aber wenn jetzt
ja
wenn ich einen Job finde ich Tatsachen
setze perfekt
[Musik]
diskutieren
katja ist ein bisschen strenger als ich
sind entspannter wir essen Eis und
hängen ein bisschen rum
wir sagen Mama nicht dass wir Eis essen
aber du verrätst uns immer
es ist wichtig für Sie da zu sein ihr
die wichtigen Sachen beizubringen
ihr das Gefühl von Liebe und Sicherheit
zu geben
ich glaube sie hat hier was sie braucht
Familie
[Musik]
ich mag keine Unordnung sondern
Sauberkeit katja ist anders sie macht
sogar mehr durcheinander als naria
da braucht jemandem der auf die beiden
aufpasst
[Musik]
wir verbringen Katja der AJ und naria
häufig am Strand
[Musik]
am wohlsten fühlt
hast das Verantwortung
eine wie ihn vom Meer weg
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wahnsinnig hübsch wahnsinnig schön und
ich behalte sympathisch
gleichinteresse und dann Sport ja und
damals immer noch sportlich und ja
klar
kann ich auch andere Kontakte in im
Osten
in Russland ist mit ihrer ins Gespräch
kommen mit ihrer mit ihrem katako bin
ich mir klar dass die andere Kontakt
abblocken und das ist mit dass sie das
mit jeder Ernte
der Martin und Lana nennt sich vor
sieben Jahren per Internet verliebt und
gliederfarbe kyratet
[Musik]
das geht jetzt
in der offen
der Martin ist überzeugte Vegetarier
bequem
vor allem sind ihrem gemeinsamen Sohn
der Leon auf der Welt ist
Tradition
[Applaus]
so Papa ist hungrig
wenn man sich Viet Lana und der Martin
übers Internet kennenlernt kann man
schon vorher im ersten Treffen
und nachher ja noch ein bisschen
[Musik]
natürlich schon relativ HPG nachdem sie
das Gefühl gehabt
und dann ist das verstehe ich sie
zumindest
cool Schwangerschaft
[Musik]
ich hatte viele Möglichkeiten zu
heiraten aber das wäre nicht aus Liebe
gewesen dann kam Martin wow Buch
ich hatte wegen meines Englisch
eigentlich damit gerechnet deinen
wesentlich älteren Engländer zu heiraten
zu werden
wir werden jetzt essen
ich muss arbeiten okay vielleicht
kannst Du essen
das für dich das für uns
es ist alles plant gesehen aber dann hat
leer wieder zwischengefunktion
[Musik]
leider leider wir probieren
perfekt Englisch können oder und
dann haben wir sicher nicht die
Möglichkeit zum irgendwelche
philosophische tiefgründige Gespräche
nicht aber ich habe mir eine Erinnerung
dass sie in früherer Bezüge da
wahnsinnig tiefgründig diskutiert haben
[Musik]
immer wieder ladet Lana ukrainische
Freundinnen zu sichern
zum Miteinander
in unserer russischen Muttersprache
können wir unsere Emotionen viel besser
und wortreicher miteinander teilen
wir können hier frei von der Seele
plaudern und unseren Gefühlen freien
Lauf lassen
[Musik]
Unterschied zwischen der schweizerischen
und der ukrainische Mentalität
besprechen der Katharina ihre Ehe zum
Beispiel hat
sie hat sich vor ihrem schweizerische
Direktor aber auch viel offener wir
sagen was wir denken die Schweizer
halten sich in der Regel zurück sie
finden dieses direkte auftreten frech
frech
die sprichwörtliche ukrainische
Gastfreundschaft Lana verteilt
wie viel ist
7/8 von 1.000 850 okay
und hier ist produktprodukte
[Musik]
also
seit 22 Jahren ist der Martin
Oberstufenlehrer
erleben mit dieser Demokratie mit mit
diesem Wirtschaftssystem was mir alles
sehen und von Politik
von mehrere ist kein Grund zu werden
und
sowieso
eigentlich eher wegwählen aus der
Ukraine
ja ja
[Musik]
wir haben Familie Aufgaben Mini
das ganze Sozialabbau
wo Kinder
ich war erstaunt und fühlte mich sehr
geliebt ich fragte mich ob ich dasselbe
gemacht hätte und ich bin nicht sicher
ob ich das damals gekonnt hätte
[Musik]
Brigit und DJ
Native American vom Stamm von der
narcota und Brigitte
[Musik]
so überwältigend dass die beiden sich
mit dem indianischen dank erkenntlich
zeigen Ritual
verlangtabak verstreut
so unendlich wie die vom Montana so
bescheiden
ja
wir sind in der Schweiz
speziell gesehen wie ich
sie hat Dusche
einfach mega cool gefunden aber das ist
einfach so spontan
und weiß nicht was Austria spontan
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sollten nicht weinen aber ich habe
geweint in diesem Tag aus lauter Glück
[Musik]
aber es stimmt ich war so glücklich
s beautiful
[Musik]
und wenn du auf die Straße
die Hochzeit hat sich rasch zu einem
größeren Event entwickelt wir wollten
zuerst etwas kleineres machen
du kannst meine Familie nicht
willkommen zu hause Schatzi
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hin und her ist schwierig
das sind dann sehr intensive Momente
ganz viele Aktivitäten dann muss man
sich wieder ziehen lassen
allein jetzt bin ich wieder glücklich
dass das vorbei ist
das ist eine große Erleichterung das
befreit den Geist
sie macht gern Pläne ich schaue was
passiert das Change die Dinge ändern
sich man kann gar nicht planen das ist
wie das neuseeländische Wetter das
wechselt auch alle fünf Minuten
es kommt immer alles gut und wenn nicht
dann findet sich eine Lösung
einen Plan nicht zu viele Pläne machen
im Leben
ein paar ein paar ja
[Musik]
Auckland die größte Stadt von Neuseeland
da wohnten
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
du würdest
[Musik]
ST
du Mädchen Amona
[Musik]
hast du dich verändert dass du Vater
geworden bist
das geschieht wohl allen aber das ist
eine gute Veränderung
man hat eine neue Sicht auf die Dinge
man kann nicht nur auf sich selber
achten und tun und lassen was man will
da gibt jemand anderen zu Hause das ist
gut
[Musik]
gestorben ist
kurzfristig
ich habe hart gearbeitet um ihn in
unsere Familie zu integrieren
wir wollten ihn unbedingt genau gleich
behandeln wie unsere anderen Kinder
was denkst du werden a.j und Katja
zurück in die Schweiz gehen um dort zu
leben
nein das glaube ich leider nicht
a.j kann Neuseeland nicht verlassen
das hat mit seiner Kindheit zu tun ihm
fällt die Geborgenheit
dass wir wohl sehr hart für Katja
große Herausforderung für ihre Ehe
wenn man frisch verliebt ist denkt man
man könnte das Leben zu zweit auf einer
einsamen Insel verbringen aber mit den
Jahren zeigt sich eine andere Realität
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wäre auch immer ist dass der
wahrscheinlich
schwieriger findet und dass man eben
halt Freiheit der immer mal wieder
heizen
[Musik]
immer erreichbar fürs Büro sogar
ja
Naturwunder von Otto Ruhr
und heiße quälen und über allen meinen
intensiver
[Musik]
aber das alles interessiert naria nicht
sie wird mit ihrem Mami
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
oder schwieriger als dass du gerechnet
hast
die Frage
schwieriger ist eigentlich nur das für
mich auf jeden Fall ist eigentlich nur
dass ich meine Familie und Freunde
vermisst aber so Bezirk zwischendurch
hat nicht so viel Schwierigkeiten weg
will mir vor anderen Ländern
erst den eigentlich also definitiv wurde
in Wien ganz plötzlich Durchfall
ich das wirklich
und eben wir
[Musik]
Schuldgefühle
ja aber
[Musik]
gefühlt
ich glaube das macht man sich einfach
oder ich nicht
[Musik]
hart für Sie und für mich
ja
[Musik]
Freunde und Familie Drucker und ich
glaube auch ich weiß ich habe ich
parallel gefragt
und ich habe schon gemerkt dass er bis
Hund aber ich glaube du bist doch in der
Beziehung glücklich bist du schönes
am nächsten Freitag
und komplizierten starken ja
hin und weg
[Musik]
hin und weg ist eine präsentiert wurde
vor Dr Oetker